over to the news conference in avonmouth
about this uh
terrible incident that a wastewater
treatment works let's have a listen
today we've been working alongside
colleagues in the fire and ambulance
services
following a major incident at wessex
waters
bristol water recycling center in
avonmouth earlier today
emergency services were called at
approximately 11 20 am
to reports of a large explosion
involving one of the chemical tanks at
the site
off king's western lane the fire service
led the rescue operation
but sadly despite the best efforts of
all those involved
we can confirm there have been four
fatalities
this includes three employees of wessex
water and one contractor
specially trained officers have this
afternoon made contact
with each of the families of those
individuals and inform them of the sad
news
this is a tragic incident and our
thoughts and sympathies go out to them
those officers will continue to provide
them with all the support they need at
this difficult time
the fifth person was also injured but
their injuries are not believed to be
life-threatening
a thorough investigation will be carried
out into what happened today
involving a number of agencies and the
health and safety executive
in due course and we will not be
speculating
on the cause of the explosion while such
work is being undertaken
i can confirm though that this is not
being treated as a terror related
incident
the explosion happened in a silo that
holds treated biosolids before it is
recycled to land
as an organic soil conditioner i can
reassure people living in the nearby
area
that there is not believed to be any
ongoing public safety concerns
following today's events